hello and welcome to the Siemens in
America online webinar series today
we'll be talking about shop turn setup
and programming specific to turn Mel B
axis lathe I'll be your presenter Chris
Pollock I'm the head of the virtual
technical Application Center and a
resource available for you if you have
any questions specific to operation and
programming topics before we begin let's
just highlight some of the things that
we have coming up in April we're going
to be doing a part programming webinar
specific to shop mill in auto mode so in
process measuring as well after that we
have some additional webinar contents
that we'll be pushing out shortly now
all of our webinars can be found going
to our main CNC for you website so if
you want to get back to some of the
previous webinars posted you can use the
direct link the CNC webinars link or you
can use our main website and drill over
to the webinars subsection additionally
you want to check out the scenes of your
website for a lot of other extra
material there's all kinds of video
tutorials you'll find documentation and
manuals there it's a great resource for
anything sin America based while you're
there you can check out our CNC training
offering we offer in-person workshops or
training classes at our TAC or technical
Application Center in Elk Grove Village
Illinois that's right by the O'Hare
Airport all of our classes are free of
charge you can come in and attend the
classes we have three different levels
of operation and programming going all
the way up to an advanced 5-axis level
three class as well as a service and
maintenance class so take a look at the
link you can download the agenda and you
can register right on the forum for
these upcoming classes now
today's content is going to be specific
to our Siemens sent americaís for DSL
control
there are some key functions is that in
a schedule that is only really
accessible or available once getting to
the 8:40 D a lot of the other topics
we've done in the past kind of transcend
working both 8:28 and the 844 here this
is specific we're getting to a level of
advanced functionality that's specific
to the 840 D control so today we're
going to be talking as I mentioned about
B axis technology lays there turn mill
technology lathe so we're going to look
at the kinematics kind of get your head
around what do we mean by a B axis what
do we mean by a turn mill machine tool
we're going to get into how do we handle
the machine in an operation set up an
operation scenario setting tools
calibrating tools that kind of stuff and
we're going to look at a live
programming example it's going to go
through all of the typical operations
you would do when programming a machine
with this kind of technology from there
we're going to go start with some basic
features and functions everything is
going to be around the shop turn built
in conversational programming
environment but you'll find a lot of
these a lot of these features and
functions will mimic or may mirror the
functionality we would be doing if we
were writing a g-code program now I
always like to reference before we begin
where you can find some supporting
documentation on the topics we talk
about these webinar series
so this content of this topic you want
to look for the shop turn operation and
programming manual you can find that at
our support industries seems calm
website or portal we like to call it so
in there generally either have you
search for the content name in this case
if you sure it's for shop shop turn
operation and programming you're going
to find a ton of manuals or
documentation there so what is't would
suggest is just write down or jot down
the document number right there in the
right side of your screen the 6fc
53 98 number and do the search for that
that's going to drill you specifically
to the shop turn manual if not if you
just look for shop turn
I would just pay attention to the date
of the manual the manual we're
referencing here is the 2008 edition but
in that manual you're going to find a
working with a B axis chapter and that's
going to really support or backup a lot
of the topics we talked about today not
everything but certainly especially from
the setup side and the operation side go
and take a look at those features are
those those chapters or sections now
additionally this is a webinar kind of
building on previous content certainly
building on some of the more entry-level
shop turn webinars but from an advanced
perspective this is specifically the
next series up from a nap webinar we did
on programming sub spindle lathe so if
you haven't seen that webinar I would
certainly recommend going back to it
taking a look at it you can find it
right there under the c and c dash
webinars website and in fact if you
click on the turnin it's going to be the
first one you see pop-up and then from
there you can view the recording or
download it for viewing later there's a
lot of material that we're going to talk
about here then I'm going to kind of
jump over because we've talked about it
in detail in the previous webinar and
there's a lot of stuff for us to get
through so I don't want to obviously
spend time reiterating stuff we've
already talked about
so again if you haven't seen it I would
suggest going back and taking a look at
that webinar okay so the first thing we
want to talk about and it's really kind
of a little bit of a stigma right now in
the industry is what do we call this
technology is it a turn mill is it a
mill turn why is there confusion with
this terminology so originally when this
mixed technology style machine came
about there really was only one
configuration type that was leveraging
turning and milling and that was really
a lathe that we were incorporating this
milling functionality it's only been the
last few years that motor technology has
gotten to a point specifically
leveraging torque motors where you can
take a platter of a large 5 axis milling
machine and get it to run at rpms where
you could actually turn it so
since we're so proficient in both sides
of the technology we've actually started
changing the terminology a little bit so
instead of calling everything a mill
turn we're specifically calling it what
is the base technology of the machine
tool built on so if it was originally a
lathe type of framework that milling has
been added onto and the base control or
the primary technology of the control is
a lathe that has had milling turned on
then it's what we refer to as a turn
mill in addition if it was a milling
machine frame that now has turning
capabilities and from the controls
perspective the primary technology is
milling and it has turning functionally
add functionality added into it and it's
what you would refer to as a mill turn
at the end of the day I mean you could
certainly refer to them as either or it
just gets a little confusing you're not
always necessarily sure what the base
technology is so that's why we've
adopted what we call turn mill or mill
turn so today yes we are specifically
talking about a turn mill it was a lathe
with milling functionality added on to
it so what am I going to see when I
finally get in front of machine what's
going to be different than what I've
seen in past configurations of the
Cinemark control well really the biggest
thing is the B axis functionality right
other than that the number of spindles
that would mirror a machine that has a
main spindle sub spindle and live tool
in turret so you're going to see the
same number of spindles but here now we
have a B axis from the physical
configuration side I now have a machine
that has one primary driven spindle just
like the machining center spindle and
now I can program it through the B axis
orientation in any range of motion
generally about at least 180 degrees of
motion sometimes even more 120 130 so I
can start to swing it around now how
does it configure differently than a
standard traditional a with a normal
traditional style turret it's really
where the reference kind of comes from
so the machine is all going to be
referenced from the spindle
is a pretty common commissioning method
when you get to this advanced technology
so whether it's a main spindle sub
spittle machine with a more traditional
turret on it or it's a B axis lathe
everything's coming off the primary
spindle face with that being said a
fixed turret is going to work all of its
offsets based off of a datum on the
turret face somewhere relative to the
turret body and then all of your tool
officers are going to stack off that in
a B axis lathe that datum is actually
the center of the B rotary and then
there's a dynamic offset working in the
background of the control that's
managing what we call our kinematics
that's the makeup of the machine and
then what will happen is there's a known
value that goes from the center of the
rotary to the gauge line which is
generally the face of the spindle and
then all of your offsets are going to
stack from there so when you set up a
tool you're still going to see that the
also it's going to be from this middle
face out but the system is actually
managing a value from the center of the
rotary out and that's how we can
dynamically adjust as we start to rotate
the B axis around so what am I going to
see a little more detail this would be a
very typical configuration of machine
tool in this technology so we have an X
Y Z driving that milling spindle around
in space then we're gonna have a main
spindle could be called any number of
different terminology each builder looks
to kind of change what they call their
spindles such usually the first thing I
do when I get in front of a new machine
is just figure out what's the
terminology they're using is it s1 is it
c1 is it some other number some some
builders like to always use the same
terminology of the spindle locations and
then if your machine just doesn't have
that type of spindle like a like a
secondary turret let's say then they
just skip over that one so that's pretty
common method too now when looking at
the V axis it's important to start to
kind of get your head around where is
this b0 where does everything derive
from so if you look at the image on the
right side you can see this is a very
very typical configuration of setup for
a B axis lathe
in this case the primary be zero
location is actually at nine o'clock so
the position that you see that head
sitting which is the primary tool
positions facing the main spindle and
then everything is going to drive
relative to that also so if I want to
tell this tool to swing down from 9
o'clock to 6 o'clock I'm actually going
to give it a be 90 positive value and
she's going to rotate counterclockwise
down to that position if I want to get
to the sub spindle I'm going to give it
a hundred and eighty so the biggest
things going to get around is where is
it referencing the v-0 different
builders can do different things but
this would be probably one of your more
common methods of setting up these
machine tools
now how do I start to drive this B axis
around through the interface screen well
what we've done was we've incorporated
two additional fields that you're going
to see in a bunch of our standard cycles
and functions so first in TSM screen or
we should all be used to the TSM screen
for allowing us to do tool changes fire
bar spindle will do stuff like that what
you're going to now see a what we call a
beta field which is that that little B
insignia and then our Y field or our
gamma field so beta is going to refer to
the angle that we're driving the B axis
to and then gamma is going to refer to
the spindle orientation of the live
spindle for that milling spindle so if
we can imagine or if we reference the
right side image I have a turning tool I
want to start to orient that and then
move it around in space well certainly I
can swing the B axis with the beta field
from zero again which is at nine o'clock
swing it down and then I can use the
gamma which is the orientation of the
spindle to then flip that insert around
so in my little right hand view there
that right hand turning tool if I want
to cut the outside of the part I would
leave it at some some angle probably 45
degrees or less it could be at zero and
I would leave my orientation of my gamma
or my spindle at zero but if I want to
take that same tool and now come down
the face of the part I may want to
invert it at an angle greater than 45
probably all the way to 90 but once I
get out past that point now my inserts
pointing the other direction is a
right-handed tool so I spend my my gamma
around or my spindle around 180 degrees
just by inputting a value of 180 and the
system now allows me to put the tool in
such a fashion where I can come down
what's nice about the system is it's
going to track appropriately handle the
spindle directions based on the
orientation and also dynamically adjusts
for your tooling offsets based on this
orientation but you have to use the beta
and the gamma fields to drive this so
let me let me show you what I'm talking
a little bit
I'm going to transition over to Sydney
train
Sydney train is our machine tool control
emulator obviously I'm running this one
on PC but the the process would be the
same so that let's say for argument's
sake I have a tool it's sitting at the B
0 or the beta 0 location
I've got a standard roughing tool in the
spindle and I want to see kind of what's
going to happen so I'm going to position
this machine to a known location so
maybe I'm going to go to 300 millimeters
this one has a metric obviously would be
the same if we were running this thing
in inch then I'm going to wrap in the
machine to this location and I can't get
quite get there two outputs loadable
work offset real fast the offsets turned
on okay and now let's go to that
position again
alright so I'm sitting at 300 z0 and if
you can picture a picture it in your
head the right-handed tool is pointing
at nine o'clock or at zero now watch
what happens to the numbers if I use the
TSM field and type in a beta value 45
degrees so I'm swinging it down to
basically that you know 7:30 position
right so I'm going to cycle start
machine drives down to 45 degrees but my
physical position location changed now
the Machine didn't move the linear axes
so this is a dynamic offset but that's
not a five axis tool path per se but
what it did do is it calculated based on
that move where I would have to go to to
get back to that zero point so systems
automatically calculating for that if I
look at the actual motion of the machine
nothing really occurred so if I'm going
to be sitting back here at a b0 and I
look at my actual values right and I
swing the system down I'm going to swing
it down the actual values is showing
what the motors are doing I swing it
down to 45 you see my display doesn't
change but
the numbers did recalculate so that's
how we kind of track and we can
automatically adapt for however I decide
to set this tool it's all being driven
by the fact that we have the Swivl cycle
on currently on this machine that's
what's tracking these numbers this is
our dynamic fixture offsets what would
have happened if I did the exact same
move I'm going to go back to zero if I
did the exact same move but I positioned
it with the B axis field here well if I
Drive it with a direct axis of B she's
not going to adjust anything so you see
my numbers didn't change it all stayed
the same so you want to be very careful
when you start to move these machines
around and you're using these types of
functionality that you're driving it
through the beta and that gamma field
because that's going to that's going to
allow the rapid calculation of the total
offset so now I can go back I'm going to
want to be in a safe spot obviously
before I tell it to move because she is
going to swing that tool down but that's
what's going to start to track and allow
the system to manage the point in space
where you're sitting at okay so this is
how I'm going to start to handle working
with my live spindle with this beta in
this gamma field now when I build the
tools I'm going to build them again
picturing everything is at that nine
o'clock location or that B zero location
so when you make a tool just like you've
made probably a thousand times over
building different tool configurations
now with the B axis laid again I'm going
to think that the tool is sitting and
that base is zero location so that's
where my cutting edge orientation
position is going to come from so when I
go to build that new roughing tool and I
go to look at that first cutting edge
option that is that tool sitting at a
v-0 with the gamma or the spindle
sitting at zero so if I have a right
handed tool I'm going to use that first
option and that would be traditionally
used for OD work but now that I have a B
axis and I can move things around I'm
not limited to just using that tool for
OD work right I could use it
pointed at the V I pointed at nine
o'clock with a spindle orientation of
zero for an OD you know turn but now I
can index my spindle 180 degrees take
that same tool go right into a bore and
do an IV turn so that's what makes these
B axis machines so much more versatile I
can start moving this cutting edge
around anywhere I want in space now if
I'm going to build the base orientation
of the tool say it's a left-handed tool
as my you know in this primary
configuration then I'd use the third
orientation field over which would be
typically what I would have done for a
boring bar now the offsets everything is
going to work off of a gauge line
typically what you'll see in these
machines is HS k63 or some HS k mount so
that means that the gauge line is truly
coming off of the face of the spindle
because that's where an HS cake contacts
if you happen to have a cat for tea or
something
then you do need to just know where gage
line is because in a cat 40 gage line is
actually inside the spindle even on a
big plus even though they're contacting
off the face the true gage line is still
inside the spindle but the offsets so
our WF and our LF our lengths and our
lengths NZ and our offsetting in X
that's coming from that gage line and
then the system is going to manage that
distance that I mentioned earlier which
is the center of the rotary to the gage
line or face of my spindle that's
happening in background and that value
is critical because if you can imagine
we start swinging that B axis around if
I don't know that distance I could never
get come up with a proper calculation of
where that tool is now that I kicked it
down to 45 degrees that's the nature so
as you start to do some tool setup
you're going to see the offset values
are going to be that distance you could
obviously have set these two losses up
externally and just plug the numbers
directly in now when we get to turning
tools that's going to be a little bit
different but it's certainly simpler
actually because in this case there is
no X offset right it's a rotating tool
so everything's held concentric to the
center of the spindle so anything I have
to give it here is going to be my
or distance that I won field distance
from gage line out to the tool tip and
then the cutter diameter now when you
build the orientation of the tool you
don't have to worry about all these
different handed or you know orientated
live tool holders that you would have in
a traditional turret because you're
going to drive it around the B axis so
everything is going to be built at that
nine o'clock position so the tool is
pointing towards the headstock and then
you're going to swing the tool from a
facing tool to a peripheral or OD
orientate tool to a back turn tool
that's all going to be handled with the
beta the beta field and you don't
actually even have to worry about gamma
right because the tools spinning so
there's there's no worrying about
orientating the the live spindle portion
of it so build all your drills build all
your animals as if they're pointing
towards a head socket v-0 and then let
the system swing them around now when
you get to this more advanced technology
of course you can kind of do more things
so there are some new tools that start
to become available to you in this
technology range and one of the tools
that's pretty neat is what we call a
multi-tool so a multi-tool allows you to
have a single tool location but it can
handle up to multiple types of
configurations so here on the image on
the right you can see I got a holder and
it's holding two different types of
turning tools probably a roughing in a
finishing tool and that's even holding a
threading tool as what we refer to as a
multi-tool now if your machines
configured for multi-tool capabilities
then you will see the option multi-tool
in the selection under favorites when I
go to create a new tool and here it's
pretty simple really all I'm going to do
is I'm going to select the multi-tool
field once I go in to create a
multi-tool I'm going to give it a unique
multi-tool name and tell how many
locations I want now if I want to be
able to control the true orientation of
each location I'm going to put a
checkbox in the angle input field or if
I leave the checkbook out then it's
going to automatically set the spacing
between each tool to be a constant
amount once I've created that
then I'm going to get a field where I'm
going to see the multi-tool in a
specific tool location that's in this
case I'm in pocket 10 and then I can
build however member of cutting edges I
told it or however many of locations
shall I say I told it within that
multi-tool and a bit alike I build any
other tool but what's going to happen is
when I told change the multi-tool I
grabbed you know number one the CMG or
number two the V nmg it's going to go
grab and bring in all of these tools
into one shot into the spindle so when
you start to build these types of tools
let's kind of transition over and show
you a little bit of what's happening so
again as a as a review if I'm building
standard tools build it with the
orientation sitting in the nine o'clock
position so a standard right hand OD
tool I'm going to use this first
position if it was a left handed tool
I'm gonna use the third position over
and my ground tools are is always going
to be built facing the B zero location
and then you're going to swing them
around appropriately now when you get to
multi tools here I have a couple
pre-built or I can create one I'm just
going to go down to a new location and
when I hit new if I have it I'm going to
see the multi-tool field that's also
what this MT column means so a lot of
times you might see that your machine
has M tll not quite sure what is
referring to it's referring to
multi-tool capability you have to have a
positionable spindle for this to work
however so select multi-tool say okay
tell it how many locations we're going
to want give it some kind of a unique
name so I'm on my multi-tool number
three if I want to type in the angles or
not and then say okay and it builds the
multi-tool and you get these three
different locations these are physical
locations that were all tied to the same
tool so now it's going to be the same
process they've been going to make a
left hand tool so I'm going to call mine
a CNM G project my caps to be on it's my
gee I don't know 3:31 oh c'mon
whatever they build the tool from there
then you would certainly build up the
other the other locations when you tool
change it you're going to pick the name
of the tool like you normally would and
then it's going to automatically go grab
the multi-tool and then orient the
spindle to this location number so
that's the multi-tool function you're
going to start to see the multi tools
become much more popular in this type of
configuration because certainly it saves
tool change locations turret locations
are tool change or locations I get three
tools in one pocket of my tool chain
okay so transitioning back now that
we've kind of talked about the setup and
the creation of tools the next thing
would be setting my work offsets so this
is going to follow that previous webinar
I referenced the sub spend l main
spindle machine so here I'm going to set
up two different work coordinates I'm
going to have a primary work coordinate
at my main spindle spindle on the left
and then I'm going to set up secondary
work offset my case going to use a G 55
54 55 for my sub spindle and that one is
going to be the one that has the mirror
function in it and the mirror is very
important because not only is this now
going to manage the z-direction like it
did in the previous webinar that I
showed but the system is also going to
handle the beta and the gamma
orientation that you're going to start
to see when we write a part program so I
can still method eyes everything as if
it's on that main spindle and then when
I apply it to the sub spindle it'll
calculate the appropriate orientation
angle has to drive the B axis to what it
has to do the live tool as far as
positioning of my gamma and then
additionally where the work offsets are
what direction is he's moving in so all
that's being handled just by a simple
mirroring of the z-axis so it it
dramatically reduces the complexity of
programming switching between main
spindle and subsequent and all that kind
of stuff now when you're using this
method is very important that your
machine is set up properly set up
properly specific to
the workholding so we're going to want
to make sure that we have the accurate
information sitting in this Chuck
Swindoll data that's underneath the
setting data in my offset table and
that's going to stack all these offsets
and we went through this again
in a lot of detail in the previous
webinar so just make sure you kind of
reference that you got to make sure that
the truck body and the jaw projections
are all known here because especially
when we go to do the handoff and then
start working on the back counter
spindle it's going to use all these
numbers to calculate and it'll actually
write the work coordinate 455 for you
you don't even have to touch it off but
you do need to have some valid numbers
here for this all to work properly now
when we get to setting tools you as well
have the beta and the gamma fields just
like we looked at in the TSM screen so
here make sure you either leave the tool
at the orientation it was in after tool
change or if you need to move the tool
you don't move it with the hand wheel
you don't move it with the position
screen you drive it to location using
the beta in the gamma field I can't
stress that enough
now we do have a couple area arrows and
the arrows are just a quick input so
what will happen is if I have the arrow
pointed to the left that's going to be
just telling the the beta to go to that
zero base position if I have a down our
pointed it's going to go to 90 degrees
of the B axis and if ever right our it's
going to go to 180 degrees those are
just shortcuts to be able to flip this
thing around a little bit and the
certainly the gamma is going to be the
positioning of the spindle so the zero
on the 180 are automatically going to
propagate there or if I choose the blank
one then just like the blank in the beta
I can type in whatever angular value I
need and then from there it's just going
to touch off like any standard tool
would come down and come to a known
diameter take a like little cut might
get plug it in in the X 0 whatever
diameter I'm on and now you've just
touched off that tool and the system
taking to account obviously the distance
from be rotary center to gauge line it's
going to plug in that value like we
looked at earlier from the gauge line to
the tool tip for you
I can do that as well in my Z again
using the beta in the Gamma fields and
then I could be touching to a workpiece
if I'm using the reference point
workpiece option or we also have the
ability is touching off to the main
spindle or the main chuck or the counter
truck so in this case we want to see you
come over and bring the tool physically
touching the chuck face not the
workholding face so if you looked at
again those two stacked offsets that
we're showing you for the chuck body and
the clamping you're going to touch off
to the face of the chuck body and when
you choose that it automatically does
the calculations for you now certainly
if you have preset errs you can just
drive off the preset ur and that all
gets handled and in the back end for you
this would be this would be well how I
would be doing if I want to do it
manually on the machine so now that we
got the Machine basically set up we've
driven it around a little bit we kind of
get an idea of what's happening from the
operation perspective now let's start to
look at the part programming so for us
we're going to do a simple part
programming example I want to just again
intentionally I made this pretty basic
from a geometry standpoint we're gonna
use some standard turning cycles facing
cycles but this is all about how are we
manipulating the tool with the B axis so
we're going to come in we're going to
turn an OD boss that's going to be the
boss on the right side view and then on
that right side or while it's clamped in
the main spindle we'll eventually do
some slotting some drilling some
peripheral drilling some face mail on
the peripheral flipping back and forth
then we're going to transfer the part
over then we're going to do some back
operations so we're going to break it
down I'm going to do it a couple steps
so we're going to start with a basic OD
turn and then transfer apart and then do
a back turn on it just so you can kind
of start to see how I can move a turning
tool from the main to the sub or counter
spindle and they're going to go back I'm
going to add some primary features to
that first operation section before I
transfer the part and at the end of the
day we'll have a complete complete part
machined the goal is to not only
obviously get you comfortable with how
we're handling to be axis in
a facing or a peripheral orientation but
but when we get to the later operations
we're going to then create inclined
planes and then start drilling or
milling relative to an income plane and
this is where the power the B axis
really starts to become evident so we're
going to go in
we're a create a part program like we
normally would we're going to jump over
to our program manager once we're there
we're going to use the shop turn
programming functionality to create this
part program if you are a gcode
programmer and I will do this webinar in
the future specifically G code but a lot
of the functionality we're talking about
here if you're doing any cycles at our
control on the G code side this is going
to be mimicked or mirrored let's say so
the Swivl cycle and g code cycle 800 is
the Swivl cycle that you're going to see
so it's there's a lot of good topics
here so you can kind of apply what we're
talking about today even to a G code
program because the functionality of
methodology is really going to be the
same so we're going to go in we're going
to start our program the first thing
we're going to build or create is our
header page and in the B axis technology
world is really nothing new or unique to
the B axis per se when you come to the
header page this is all kind of mimicked
just dealing with a machine that has a
main spindle and a sub spindle so the
described functionality the ability of
obviously controlling multiple spindles
from a max constant service view
perspective and then the z2w field or
staging of the sub spindle or the
counter spindle that's all going to be
handled we're not going to see anything
unique to the B axis until we get in and
start to do some physical operations so
first let's start a program and we'll
build our header page
so I want to go over to program manager
come over pro program field and let's
contribute a program you know I have a
bunch of ones that we were fooling with
before I'm going to get rid of some of
these we don't need all these programs
done all right so I'm just deleting a
few making some space and I'm going to
start a new program I want to do a shop
term program give it a name following my
standard rules letters numbers and
underscores nothing else nothing more
nothing less
I'm going to call mine sample one say ok
and we're in our header page so like I
just mentioned there's really nothing
unique here if you're but all
comfortable with driving a machine with
the sub spindle is going to be same
features and functions so the describe
for the primary work offset if I haven't
if I have a known value that that part
is sticking out again this would be the
total offset from spindle face all the
way out to the work offset I can plug it
here just be careful with this because
this is going to overwrite whatever
sitting in the work offset in my offset
table so if I come back out here and I
go to my work offset and my g54 has 175
if I don't put that value if that's
truly what I want my work offset to be
in this described field then it's
getting get overwritten so be careful
with that generally I don't usually use
the describe function for my main
spindle unless I'm in an example where
I'm doing heavy production and I want to
keep from the potential of an operator
maybe stepping on an offset then I can
just let it let it rebuild it each time
but if I'm running the machine and I
know I'm going to come over and touch
the front of my part and set my work
coordinate accordingly prior to running
the program I don't want to use describe
set up my stock in this case I get a
basic hundred millimeter blank parts 150
millimeter overall we're going to stick
75 out for the first clamping and then
we'll grab it I'll have a 75 mil for the
next clamping just keeping things pretty
simple
basic read track values I'm just going
to have an incremental five millimeter
retrack safety position for tool change
point so this is a value that I like to
get very visual when I'm out on machine
on I'll pre position the the tool in a
safe location when you get to these B
axis machines I certainly want to think
about the swinging of that B axis maybe
with the longest tool potential I want
to try to get as far away you know some
of these machines get pretty compact so
you got to be careful starting to swing
things around so here I'm going to use a
value based on the Machine coordinate
system I'm driving the machine to five
hundred fifty mill and Z of 750 and
really that's just going to be again
this is a machine coordinate value so
it's based off my spindle face
this machine has 600 millimeters of
Mac's travel an X some of that and this
machine I think is somewhere around
fourteen hundred millimeters into Z so
I'm basically centering my z-axis you're
going to know once you have workholding
stuff on what is an optimal place and
you can always jog the machines location
just use the teach function to teach you
that what's my safety clearance
certainly my max rpms to worry about it
for our webinar virtually but I would
put legitimate numbers here and then
where do I want to stage my sub spindle
what I'm done so you'll usually I'll
send the sub spindle all the way back or
just about back to the extent of the
travel so I have maximum amount of
clearance between my two spindles if
it's a production and a larger machine I
don't have to go all the way back I want
to say sometime then you can start to
trunk everything up just want to be
careful with clearance because you know
those heads they're of a decent size so
you know if you're sitting at a b0
location you're going to come all the
way down to maybe bore a hole you got to
accommodate not only the projection
distance of the tool but that whole head
so just be careful you know that's where
clearances become a little tight okay so
we accepted our header pages in now
we're going to get to our first turning
operation so looking at our content
we're going to just do a simple OD turn
nothing all that complicated
we're going to machine from 100
millimeter OD
on to a 50 millimeter OD but you're now
going to see that even in something as
simple as a stock removal OD turning
cycle you have that beta and the gamma
fields available for you that's what's
going to let you drive around the
orientation the system is automatically
going to manage it so what would happen
is this cycle off of the tool change
would apply that orientation angle that
I want to rotate it to then she would
come down to the start point and begin
machining so that wouldn't happen after
the the tools already been positioned
down and we're just going to be driving
that base orientation of the turning
tool so here we're probably going to do
it at a b0 location and then machine it
then we can kind of flip it around so
you can see that so let's add this into
our program now I'm going to bring up
the print just so you can kind of use it
for your own reference and what we're
doing is we're machining this area so if
you look at view a on the right side
we're just turning this hundred
millimeter blank of Rostock down to a 50
millimeter OD so I'm just going to go to
turning pick my stock removal and I'm
going to do my basic stock removal I
want to grab an appropriate tool so here
I'm going to use my right-handed OD
turning tool and then you come in and
these are the new fields so how do I
want to drive my my B axis do I want to
just tell it hey go to be 0 do I want to
tell the figures a little angle do I
want to swing it all the way down and
then what do I want to do for the
spindle and you see when I highlight it
the spindle or the gamma field goes
yellow so here I can type in a value or
I can choose the preset 0 or 180 so
you're going to pick any one of these
and if you don't quite have your head
around it don't worry try it
simulation is going to catch you if you
chose a solution that's not workable the
rest of cycle is the same as you guys
have always used feed speeds turning
strategy where am I starting where am I
going depth for cut and all the normal
stuff so we accept it and now as we
start to simulate a run we're going to
see our turning scenario now the trick
here is pay attention to the screw you
see on the insert because that gives you
a reference of where things are
positioned also I'm going to slow down
my override so good a little slower I'm
going to take a look at the orientation
right so this is a 55 degree insert with
minimal relief angle probably 5 or 7
degrees so you see that that insert was
almost vertical against this back wall
so as you start to drive or control the
B axis
maybe I plug in a value of 45 and I
simulate it it's going to tell you
whether or not it can get to that
location so if you choose a value too
large for it to go to so maybe I tell a
10 or so it's going to limit you or not
and then you can maybe flip some things
around so you'll control what you want
to do based on these values now if I
want to totally flip the tool around
right so I'm going to go to 90 and go to
180 that's going to turn the tool upside
down and move it around for me and again
watch that
I don't see the screw anymore because
now I'm flipped over so you can kind of
get an idea even visually here in
simulation whether or not you see that
little little screw detail based on what
position that's been tool is in so play
around with it you know if you if you
think that you know you don't quite have
your head around the orientation don't
be afraid to fool around with it
simulation will catch if you've chosen a
solution that's not viable or not
possible okay so I'm going to go back to
a base 0 location and that's just
holding the tool sitting at 9 o'clock
and now we're going to go and take a
look at a simple transfer I'm going to
minimize that so we turned it and now we
want to do a transfer so the transfer is
going to be the same as you've seen up
to now just including a beta and a gamma
field so this is really allowing you the
option of telling it where you want to
swing that B axis during the transfer
method so like I said earlier clearance
is there tight in these machines so when
I send the Machine up to its clearance
position which is going to mean the
Machine location found right here in the
cycle I may need to position that B and
if I know I'm going to immediately take
that tool and come down and work on the
subsequent oh maybe I want to position
it to 180 all right
I can I can have it swung there let it
do the transfer now I come straight down
and start doing the turning and the tool
is already over there or I can let it
handle it in the cycle other than that
it's the same exact process the g55
that's handling everything for me as far
as once I get to the counter spindle so
I don't have to worry about that so this
is just going to be driving that initial
location during the transfer once I tell
it to start to transfer is going to be a
standard pick in place in this example
so the Chuck's going to come over
counter spindle grab my part basically
my jaws would just be touching so I'd
probably have a little bit of index
offset between the two jaws clamp it
bring her back to that z2w or safety
location that was stipulated in the
header page then we're going to go in
we're going to start to machine
other side now it's important when you
start to method eyes the counter or the
sub spittle operations that you remember
that you're still always programming
everything as if it was in the main
spindle the g55 the mirrored offsets
handling everything so when it comes to
the beta and the gamma fields think of
it as if you're on the main spindle the
system will automatically orient the B
axis orient this spindle and handle the
z direction for you so it'll also handle
the direction of the spindle of the sub
spindle because that may have to spin
backwards it calculates all that for you
don't think anything that about that
just always picture that you're driving
all the data as if you were sitting on
that main spindle so let's plug that
operation in those two operations in
this case so when I get to the various
fields I want to go to my counter
spindle option here if I want to control
the positions I can plug the values in
then the rest of this is going to be the
same as I normally would for a pic in
place where do I want to send the
machine as a safety location where am i
sending the live tool in this case of
the milling spindle for my transfer
flushing coolant what directions are my
two spindles running in what RPM how far
onto the part of my going what's the
reduce feed location what is the reduced
feed rate if I want to travel to a big
stop to apply pressure am i drawing the
part out am i using a cut off cycle
again we're just going to pick in place
what's the work coordinate I'm going to
use once I get to the sub spindle very
very important and am i describing the
secondary we're offsetting here I like
to use the describe method you don't
have to you could pre stage it but the
system as long as I set up my Chuck's
properly it'll do those calculations for
me so I don't have to think about that
and referencing that previous webinar go
back and check it out if you haven't
seen it because I talked about this in a
lot of detail and we really start to
show you how those numbers get
calculated it's pretty cool so what's my
overall blank it knows how much it's
going to be sticking out by how much I
throw it
on so I'm sticking out 75 mil and where
do I want to send the sub spittle when
I'm done and you don't have to go back
to where the header page says this is
what's controlling where I'm going to go
to after the transfer so we transfer our
part now we're going to do a simple turn
but I'm going to be doing this left side
of the feature and I do have a chamfer
here so I'm going to still use the stock
removal cycle but I'm going to use the
moment champers and if you look I'm
using a B 0 and a gamma 0 orientation
typical geometry right a machining from
100 down to 50/50 mil back I'm just
putting a chamfer of 10 mil in this back
corner and then what's my depth of
caught you know normal stuff now for
this to work properly the system
actually has to jump over and
automatically orient that spindle for me
and then and then the axis orientation
to 180 and that's going to automatically
be handled so there's our basic turn I
see the insert screw so I know where I'm
sitting as far as the P Zero and spindle
orientation there's our transfer and now
you see how I don't see the aim screwed
screw anymore
and the spindle counter spindle is
actually running in Reverse system
handle that for you just by using the
mirrored work offset and allowing us to
track the bait in the gamma if you were
to do all this with B axis positions and
positioning the spindle you can start to
see how complicated this becomes what
direction drives are on the spindle am i
inverted am I not systems tracking all
that for us alright so now let's start
to get to some little more intricate or
interesting type of features let's do
some milling so when I come to the
milling cycle you're going to notice
there is no beta into gamma because
based on the orientation of the geometry
I tell it is it on my face is it on my
peripheral surface that's how we're
going to know how to stage the B axis
and I don't need to know the gamma
because the tool spinning right so that
one's obviously easy
so depending on the configurations I've
used before you may or may not have seen
the face wide function base B is
something new we're going to keep that
for a little later in this session
because that's what's going to allow me
to handle my incline planes so just as
simple as picking either a face C or
face Y strategy base C would give you C
axis motion from milling this slotting
tool path base Y would hold the main
spindle stationary whichever spindle on
running shall I say stationary and use
the y-axis of the of the machine to
machine between x and y machining this
tool path and then obviously if I needed
to go into the peripheral or the outside
part I'm either going to use the
peripheral C or the sheath Y we're going
to see that in the next operation and
then here we're just doing a standard
slotting cycle open slotting cycle so
I'm going to add that to my first stop
because if we look at our part print we
see that the slot is actually on the
right side and what I'm going to do as
well to keep from doing the transfer
because we're going to add a few
operations to this main side and kind of
let the other stuff get pushed down I'm
just going to put a quick little g-code
line in of a program stop this way I
don't have to worry about simulating the
entire process the whole time we can
kind of work on the part get that stuff
done and then I can jump over to
finishing off the back section of it go
to milling go to slotting and select an
open slot now the tool I'm going to
choose a tool that's pointing towards my
zero but I'm always going to point that
because again the axis is going to
handle swinging that tool down so all my
drills in my end mill should always be
built unless I have some kind of right
angle head in there should be built
towards the b0 location of that nine
o'clock position you notice there again
there is no beta or gamma here because
everything is being driven based on what
I choose all right am i working on the
outside surface and we're working on the
face and that's where the system will do
its calculations from the rest this is
just going to be standard
bird where's the center what I'm what's
my technology or my toolpath strategy
climb mil dimensional mil am I just
doing one slot multiple now the C
orientation position that becomes
important this is how I can kind of
clock where the slot is so I'm going to
have this slot via @ @ c 0 basically so
it's going to machine a slot straight up
and down and then I got to think about
that later with my other features right
I got a couple flat so I get to put on
this part and some drilled holes and
they're 90 degrees off the slot you just
got to pay attention to that that's how
I can kind of clock the feature around
the rest of this is just your center
right center of it top of the part
lengthen width of my slot so 16 mil wide
50 mil long something just a little bit
greater then angle of orientation if I
need to depth
this would be my radial engagement my
spiral step over I'm doing a 30% cutter
diameter engagement depth for paths so
I'm taking it this one just take all
uncut do I want to leave in a material
for finish cut so if we simulate it
we're not going to see the first turn
feature we're going to see the Machine
slot come and play I'm going to look at
3d here give a little bit of rotation
I'm using a face Y strategy so you're
not going to see the spindle orientated
CX orientating if I use the AC then the
y axis would be held stationary now get
our slot and the system calculated the B
zero position because it knows based on
the location of the slot now it didn't
move on because I got my program stopped
if I hit cycle start again it would have
continued on done the transfer and moved
on through the program so for us the
next feature is going to naturally be to
face off these two flats so not only do
I have the flats created what I can
drill or maybe tap or whatever I'm doing
some holes on these flats so just like
you saw before no beta no gamma
I'm going to
choose the appropriate location now when
use the face mill cycle you don't have
the peripheral C option because of the
nature of a facing operation is it's
flat it's not wrapped around a radius
the way a pocket could be so pocket
you're going to see either the sheath Y
which is using the y axis of the machine
or the peripheral c but when you get
space mail you only get the sheets Y so
you won't even see the ability to doing
a face mill operation on the peripheral
if you have a machine that doesn't have
a y-axis I have yet to see a B axis lay
that didn't have all my access these are
generally the Big Daddies right of all
the machines so they're going to have
all the functionality in our case we're
going to chain or we're going to create
two face mill cycles and they're just
going to be 180 degrees apart first one
starting at an index of 90 because I
want it clocked 90 degrees off that slot
in the slot was at zero and then the
next one when I look at it it's going to
just be a mirror image of the other one
and it's going to be 180 out and what I
also want to do is I want to make sure
that I gate my facing cycle so I don't
over cut here so we're going to use a
basic position and then tell it to limit
the overall location so back into our
program I'm going to insert below open
slots which will make sure my highlights
sitting on open slot I'm going to put a
milling face milling I don't have to
keep telling the tool I'm sits that's
redundant but if I start to move things
around it's kind of nice added tool in
there because I don't have to remember
what was modally loaded that's kind of
up to you
beads in spades all the same position of
it so remember I said you don't see the
peripheral see here because the nature
of a facing cycle is going to be flat
and that can't be flattened is wrapped
around a radius but I could do a face in
the Y or facing the B all right so here
but all the facing cycles require a
y-axis to be there make sure I limit the
depth right so my X is going to go
you're going up and down byesies
and forth so that's in a Z direction and
the Y is across the part where do I want
my first position to be probably 90
degrees 90 degrees now the back edge
according to my print if I look at it
this back edge is 50 millimeters back so
I'm just saying hey I'm going to start
50mm back and I'm leaving a little bit
on my my-y so we're going to say 50 mil
on one side my X is going to be my
location but this isn't diametric this
is this is radial when you get to
milling cycles so if I got a diameter a
40 mil then the finished surface is
actually a 20 and the rough surface
because it's cylindrical is actually out
at 25 so I want to start at 25 and then
later we're going to end at 20 and then
how far over do I want to go in my
y-axis hunter mill should be fine this
way I'm giving a 50 50 ml on either side
but I don't need another 50 mil off of
the Z zero which is the face so I can
just come back 50 mil from my negative
that's going to do a feature that starts
at this back edge and comes out and
again I am limiting my depth by this
field step over step 4 cut will just
take it all in once one shot we can go
right back to the facing cycle actually
I'm going to copy mine and we'll paste
it in and open it up and now I can give
it just the 270 and as long as I made
all my numbers right on the first one I
should get two flats
you
okay so with city there's our slot now
we're going to index 90 degrees as you
can start machining across since I gated
the surface it's going to try to always
start at the furthest point away and
slide starting out and is he positive
even though I gave it the dimensions
working backwards really matter six of
one half dozen the other and we get our
two flats we get our two flats 90 to 180
degrees opposed and ninety degrees off
of the slot sometimes you can get
confused where where C 0 is so I even
find myself just let's get some geometry
in and kind of get my head around where
this whole thing is falling and then if
I have to I can index things ninety
degrees from each other if I was in
cycle start again she would continue on
with the transfer and the machining of
the back op so now once I get some flats
there now we can actually drill some
holes and here I'm going to use the
standard drilling cycles the live to
drilling cycles that are in the control
we are going to link events just like
you would in the lower technology
machines the big thing here is paying
attention to the strategy I'm choosing
so is its face as a peripheral as its
sheath and making sure I carry the same
strategy through from my can cycle to my
position locations if you mix these up
these things won't change anymore and it
the position patterns always have to
change so make sure that we remember to
do that
so transitioning over to sin you train
we're going to continue on with this
example let me bring up our our print so
we can see that so what we're doing is
we're doing basically for drilled holes
we're only actually drilling - per
surface so it's hard to so I'm sure it's
hard for you guys to see two of these
are hidden in lines or hidden holes so
they're the exact same two hole
locations and the nature of us flipping
the part over puts the next positions it
looks like from the top view with the
hidden view you have four holes what
we're actually only have two so that's
what we're going to be plugging into
we're going to stop hole and that
lower-left hole and we'll do them again
on the opposing surface so below face
spilling I want to set up a drilling
cycle I'm just going to do a standard
drill ream certainly this could be a
Peck drilling or one of the other many
cycles we have according to the print
I'm doing a six millimeter hole ten
millimeters deep so I'm choosing a drill
six millimeter drill again it was
commissioned or created pointing to be
the system's automatically going to flip
the BX down 90 degrees for me to drill
these holes these and speeds I'm not too
worried about it in this case you're
going to put something more accurate
when you create your real part now do I
want to position with the y-axis or do I
want to position with the C so in my
case I have holes that are offset er
right they're offset to the center line
so I have to position and Y and just
remember this option because it's
important to reflect this when we get to
the position screen I'm a drilling depth
couple other standard shooting couple of
standard options and I accept we get the
normal open bracket so it means we have
a link it to something I'm going to link
it to my positions I'm going to use some
random holes and this is where I
mentioned you have to choose the same
strategy you notice if I choose the
wrong strategy they don't link together
so it's important to use the same
strategy and just carry it through
so what position am I starting to drill
from we said before that that bottom
flat surface is at 20 millimetres
radially so that's why I'm using a x 0
what's the orientation position of the
first set of holes so it's 90 degrees
first location that's going to be this
top hole so I'm seven millimeters offset
in the Y I see that dimensionally right
here and I'm 15 millimeters back in the
Z next hole is 7 millimeters in the
positive and I'm back thirty millimeters
so just have those two holes hit accept
now they linked because they have the
appropriate strategy I do another random
set of holes put this at 270 accept and
I should have all four holes system
automatically driving that tool down to
a B axis 90 position and drilling my
four holes let's take a look at that
you
here comes our flats certainly need
flats before we can drill holes on the
flats
you
machine they provide - a tool change
swings the be down I even see the B here
showing the 90 degrees and then she's
just sitting at my clearance position
waiting for me to come up with another
operation all right so that's how I'll
start to handle some peripheral drilling
I can do face drilling as well in fact
in our example I want to plug a or put a
16 millimeter hole straight through this
part now in my case to make it a little
bit more interesting I'm going to say
that the drill that I'm using can cannot
drill all the way through this 150
millimeter part 16 millimeter hole so
that's not a uncommon scenario so I'm
going to drill and I specifically chose
to do this right around the transfer so
I want to drill from one side half a
little over halfway through then we're
going to transfer the part and we're
going to same tool flip that spindle 180
degrees finish drilling on the backside
and we'll get our through hole now just
to keep things a little bit more
interesting I decided to use the solid
drill functions you're going to get a
chance to see how solid drill is created
and then I'm going to use a centric
drilling cycle because maybe in this
case I want to actually hold the drill
stationary and spin the main spindles
for the sub spittle I don't always have
these live tools I can still use
eccentric scenarios it's kind of six and
one half dozen another really doesn't
make any difference either way but the
cycles are still there so let's take a
look at that
so back here after my positions I'm
going to want to go to drilling and go
to my centric which is my first option
up right the rest of these cycles down
below these are all live tool cycles
right so that's going to run the milling
spindle the centric is going to run the
main spindle holding the tool rigid in
the other location my tool is going to
be a solid drill now the solid drill
when building a solid drill let me just
get to a
new location you're not going to see it
in the favourites so if you're looking
for something you don't find in the
favourites go and drill down into the
different color options under drill
I see solid drill so what's the
difference between a solid drill and a
twist drill so solid drill you can still
run live this is being really referred
to what we like to call an insert style
drill and the biggest thing is the solid
drill sorry the solid drill doesn't
force you to put an angle value in
because it's assuming that it's got a
flat bottom so if I have a tool that's
flat bottom drill I like to use a solid
drill it just keeps me from having to
plug in the numbers to kind of mimic a
flat bottom right other than that it's a
standard drill so diameter projection
from the spindle face out to the tool
tip now it's centric so in the centric
cycle it can only ever allow this to
drill at a B 0 or a be 180 location so
we don't have the ability of flipping to
a peripheral surface or anything because
centric the nature center gets spinning
the spindle the tool is being held
stationary so we fill out the rest of
cycle as normal how deep am I going the
Fulani is pack what would be my Mac spec
I'm taking an all-in-one shop I'm going
to get rid of the program stop because I
don't need it anymore we're going to do
the transfer and I'm going to simply
copy and paste the centric drilling I'm
not going to do anything different
because the work coordinates going to
handle where it's going to drive this
tool to do it so if I look at it now
we're going to get a hole on both face
and then we come back now quick little
trick I can do control em to speed up my
simulation and get back down but hitting
control up again so now I can just get
my partial drilled hole do my transfer
and there's my rest of my drilled hole
and then she's going to come down and
she's going to finish turning the part
we can look at this and a half cut view
and we can rerun it so you give you guys
a little different perspective so we're
turning it kick up the speed a little
bit with control M now we're drilling
our peripheral holes now our tool is
going to come in so there's our partial
drill just passed email we do our
transfer over and now we're doing the
rest there would be our blend finish up
good so we're getting there we're just
about done or we're over at this side of
things so now we got some interesting
stuff we're going to get a chance to see
how do I handle inclined planes and
that's really where I want to get to
right because I got a B axis way so I
want to use features that are going to
allow me to take advantage of the B axis
ways
so looking at our slides once I get to
incline planes I need to start to
understand a little bit what we mean by
the Swivl cycle or cycle 800 swivel
cycle or cycle 800 does two key features
or functions for me it allows me to
create an inclined plane and then set my
tool normal orientation to that plane or
it allows me to drive the orientation of
the tool but it's not going to move the
work coordinate system and really that's
the difference between the left option
the left feature you see on the left
side or the right side what happens to
the work coordinate system as the work
horn is saying saying station is saying
fixed and it's just changing your
orientation and managing the orientation
of the tool that's what's happening with
the beta and the gamma excuse me that
should have been on silent that's what's
happening with the beta in the Gamma
fields right that's really doing that
orientation of tool option if I want to
create a plane and then have my z plane
be normal to that surface or the
orientation be perpendicular to the
plane and then the tool automatically
aligned to that plane I'm going to use
the orientation of the machine and
that's what we call our swivel cycle so
the swivel cycle allows me to do a
couple things it allows me to move the
zero around linear it allows me to
rotate the zero and then it allows me to
move the zero around again on this new
rotated plane and at the end when it's
all said and done the tool is going to
be sitting perpendicular to that surface
and my Z is now going to be coming
straight up from the surface the Z is no
longer going to be on the face of the
part and this is what we call swiveling
with the swivel cycle instead of
orientating the tool so for our example
we want to create a plane so we're going
to use the swivel cycle feature and I'm
going to move my zero around a little
bit too so when I look at this maybe for
those of us that have seen or used to
cycle a hundred on a more of a milling
type of configuration or variation very
very similar fields actually a couple
things that get
pulled out of here that you would have
over on the mill side but pretty much
it's almost identical so I can do a tool
change I can do a retrack strategy here
this is unique I can clock or orientate
the C position you wouldn't obviously
have that in a milling machine but I
would have it on a turn mill so that's
where I can kind of spin my C around
just like you've been seeing in the
other cycles or how do i position my ski
for that feature the linear shift the x
0 y 0 Z 0 that's a linear staging of the
work coordinate system so it's that's
doing that normal to the original
coordinate system of the part then my
swivel mode and my swivel method is now
going to allow me to start to rotate
things around so now I can rotate my or
create a plane and then once I've
created the plane or rotated I can then
shift my 0 along that plane so in our
case we're going to drill a hole in the
center of the plane that we make we
looked at our print again we have two
45-degree surfaces we drill a couple
holes in them
so here I can shift things around once
I'm all done what's happening well if I
can picture my work horn system and here
you have a little coordinate cube
displayed initially before I start the
swivel cycle right my x and z is front
center of my part where it normally
would be on any length wise Center as
well so this first shift of 10
millimeters in X it's really just going
to slide the 0 up to that corner that I
want to pivot on all right that's going
to be the corner of my plane and I know
that because I have a known dimension on
my print it's important that you would
have that value on your print now I want
to rotate the coordinate system and I
want to rotate in my case simply around
the y axis and I'm rotating in a plus
direction so that's why I have a plus
value in the Y field of 45 degrees so
the result of that is now your
coordinate system is sitting still on
that corner of the surface but now my Z
is normal to or perpendicular to this
new inclined plane that will last but
not least and
I don't have to do this but sometimes it
makes it easier later I'm going to stage
the zero by sliding the work horn system
up this new created plane in my case
we're going to move up the x-axis in a
positive direction 10 millimeters so now
if I was to tell a tool go to 0 0 0 for
X Y Z it should be touching that center
point of that plane that's where my new
0 is at the time of the swivel function
from there once I've swiveled in place I
can now use the facing cycle and we're
now going to get to use the face B
function so face B is referring to the B
axis and if you want to do anything in
an inclined plane with a swivel cycle
active you need to use face because face
Y or sheet Y is going to then negate
this plane you just created and go back
to the standard base orientation of the
work coordinate system so by selecting
face B we're saying apply this tool path
to the plane that was just created so I
do have to have created a plane prior to
this so your operations like you see
here you're going to have a swivel plane
and then once you've created the plane
tell it how you're cutting this and this
would be the same thing in G code you'll
have a cycle 800 which is a swivel plane
and then you'll have a bunch of
operations and that could be just G
zeroes ones and twos whatever it takes
to do that feature but that's now active
to the corresponding swivel plane so
we're going to do this for one side and
then we get a chance to kind of flip it
over and do the next side so let's get
one surface in created so I'm going to
move my highlight below my stock removal
because certainly I would want to have
turned this feature down prior to
putting these two flats and here you can
see this is where I have some known
values right in this view a field
I know that the edge of my plane is 20
millimeters diametrically where in a
kind of a more of a milling type of
scenario so this becomes a radial value
that's my I shift 10 mil up I got my 45
degrees
about my y-axis that's why we have a
positive 45 no why
and then if you look I know the
centerline of the hole that I'm going to
put in later is 10 millimeters off of
that edge so that's how I know to slide
my zero 10 millimeters up in my x-axis
now we're a swivel plane exist it's
found under the various cycles and you
have a button called swivel plane now
the swivel plane I guys mentioned
there's two strategies right you have
the swivel plane for creating planes or
you have the orientate tool you do have
an orient orientate tool option as well
here we were allowing it all happen
using the beta and the gamma field in
the cycle if I'm not using a cycle let's
say but I need to change the orientation
of my tool and then come down and do
something without moving my coordinate
system you could use the orientate mill
tool and in g-code cycle 800 has that
same variation so you can do an or a
tateville tool with cycle hundred as
well in the g-code side or the swivel
plane we're choosing swivel plane now
here I'm probably going to want to grab
the tool that I'm going to be using so
we're going to be using a twelve
millimeter tool to mill this surface so
I'll let it do a tool change now we got
a retrack plane wherever I want to back
up to and I'm done where am i
orientating my see I may not know this
so machine your first surface and see if
everything seems to be aligned the way I
want it if not you can clock it I was
sliding my X up ten my Y wasn't changing
my Z wasn't changing so that was putting
me right at this corner right at the
pivot point I'm doing a positive 45
degree rotation and then I'm doing a
final shift in my X 10 millimeters up
positioning me to the center probably
one of the biggest things you want to
get your head around once you start
programming this method is where is the
coordinate system when you're all said
and done so if you can get your hands on
a little coordinate cube they're very
very helpful but at the end of the day
just like we saw
in our previous slide the coordinate
system is going to be sitting right here
so Z straight up Y is across the part
and X plus is going kind of back towards
the chuck and that's important once we
start putting in our physical cycle in
this case a milling face mill cycle
because I got to kind of think about
where the geometry is so we got twelve
millimeter tool some speeds and feeds I
need to make sure I choose base B I'm
not worried about gating anything as far
as my cutter path everything is kind of
open around it so I can leave that and
now we're going to choose our amount of
kind of facing so the center of this
feature is zero zero so here you know
how much in my X do I really know well I
know that ten millimeter gets me from
the center of the bolt hole pattern
which probably is the center of the
feature out so I'm going to need at
least 20 mil and center is zero so if I
did maybe minus fifteen and then later
down here I did thirty let's say off of
that back edge so that's going to be
back here remember plus is up all right
so minus 15 so over there I'm going
thirty that should be okay
my Y mm-maybe will go
minus 25 and then we'll go fifty mil for
the Y now my Z is zero in this case is
something a little bit above I don't
necessarily know so I can kind of I can
kind of guess maybe I'll give it five
mil save it that does and I'm ending at
a value zero so because of the plane I
created that's establishing is easier or
to be this surface so I know I have some
plus stock how much do i have i can
mathematically calculate it I'm not that
worried I'm going to give it some plus
stock I might if it looks like it's
taking too heavy a cut I can give it a
little more stock my case I'm taking
this all one shot so
we simulate it I have to do we'll kick
it up a little faster here alright so
there is are a little bit you just
transfer they just drilled okay so now
we're in the backside we're turning and
now we're going to get bar swiveling
cycle I was just taking a hold one cup
obvious that you would put this in a
couple passes and here I see the feature
just like I see on my print is offset 90
degrees from these flats so that's where
I wanted it so my C 0 was a good
strategy so now I just got to get to the
backside so when we go to the backside
I'm just going to want to really just
mimic that same exact thing but now spin
the coordinate system 180 degrees out so
we can we can use we're going to have to
create a new plane right so this is in
the swivel plane and then I'm just going
to have a repeat of the same cycle and
that's what's going to spin it 180
degrees out for me
so I don't have to try to shift anything
into the bottom I can just pre-staged
the part so she's sitting in a plus
feature and then I'm going to get my two
flats sorry hold on one second
alright oops
now of course come here
huh give me one second here all right
let me just transition back my computer
had a little farfegnugen there alright
so I'm going to continue with my with my
my milling of my inclined plane so I
really need these two events so I'm
going to just highlight them compliment
paste them we're going to go back into
the swivel plane and I'm going to tell
it to index the swivel plane 180 degrees
and this base male feature can stay the
same I don't need to change anything
now if we simulate we should get both
surfaces
so we start turning kick the speed a
little bit transfer there's our backup
okay let it finish up here
alright faith in a seated position so
that's all being handled with that
orientation of the see in the swivel
cycle and we can jump to either two
surfaces so weird almost done we've just
got a couple holes to put on a system or
on this part and then we're going to be
done so the next thing is going to be
drilling and drilling in an inclined
plane now I intentionally kept it's
pretty easy certainly there could be a
whole bunch of holes in these surfaces
but the key here is we're drilling on
this surface so anywhere on that surface
that's created so we're going to choose
the drilling cycle and now we're going
to use the face B strategy so whatever I
want to do anything milling drilling on
an inclined plane where I'm utilizing
the B axis at a position other than 0 or
180 I use the face ability option but
with that I need to have created a
swivel plane so we're going to come in
we're going to choose our face B option
once I've given it a swivel plane and it
will use the active swivel plane just be
careful if I'm driving tool change that
plane may or may not have been
maintained it's really up to the OEM
when they go through their tool change
macro if they're going to cancel the
plane or keep it active so if you don't
know I would defer to the alternate
which is I'd rather be redundant with my
planes and from a safety perspective
because I know I just sent it through a
tool change so we'll actually add a
plane in ours come in we're going to
drill a hole we're going to choose our
location and then we'll do our next hole
and here I'm going to show you a quick
little way of doing some repeat commands
when I have some repetitions repetitious
functionality stead of having a whole
bunch of copy and pastes
so under the face mill I do need to do a
new plane so I'm going to go back to my
swivel plane now I can keep it at 180
because that's already staged that was
the last ones working on and then jump
back to zero that's okay I just want to
make sure I have the plane pick a
drilling strategy now my part if I look
at my call-out for my 8 millimeter hole
I do want to probably in this plane I'm
sorry I don't want to call out my 8
millimeter drill again created pointing
towards b0 retract
orientation locations all this stuff
stays the same I'm off to change
anything else because this is now
establishing a zero at the center of
this hole that I want to win I want to
drill so we accept it from there we're
going to use our cycle I'm just going to
do a basic cycle a millimeter I know my
depth is in my call-out which it looks
like it's 20 millimeters deep here and I
want to make sure I use the face B it's
important right and then I want to go to
my position locations I can just do some
random locations I'm going to choose
face B now the z0z is perpendicular to
the surface so z0 is going to be the top
of this plane which is where i want to
drill from and my is my location for my
drilling is zero zero I don't have any
other position so I can zero them out so
that's going to drill one hole right on
this surface now when you start to get
to some of those repetitious events it
sometimes it's nice to not have to keep
copy and pasting and maintaining the
same geometry in multiple events so
that's that's a scenario where I like to
use the repeat command now the repeat
command you can use all kinds of
different markers to tell it where to go
- probably one of the easiest things to
do is to go in and to your edit function
go to your renumber option and give
yourself some n numbers so once I plug
in too many numbers I have some
automatic point locations so what do I
need to do well I need to do a new
swivel plane back to zero so we're going
to do a swivel plane back to zero but
now I really need to just redo these two
events and 180 and 190 and let me just
do a whoops
renumber get a number on that one too so
they're all the same so if I do a quick
little g-code line type the word repeat
space and what add numbers I want to
repeat between if you wanted to just do
one you'd have to just duplicate the
number twice my case I want to go n 182
and 190 and now we should get holes on
both sides another way with sequence
numbers is really handy if you please go
to like I could add to go to in the
beginners program and jump really over
all this first op stuff and allow me to
just pick up at the back side but here
let's just run it across let's speed it
up a little bit so that we're doing our
turning there's our inclined mil plane
right the first plane spin it that since
I drilled it 180
it shouldn't spin again it should just
come right down drill my hole
there's my drilled hole there's my next
drilled hole and if I did my job
properly in my position and my depth we
should break through we should get a
nice little break through so I'm going
to do a cut view let's cut it right
there and there we see a cross hole came
through broke through it did not dig on
the other side this is just the break
through there so it looks like my
numbers were good right so just about
done I can uh attack utt for now so
final operation looking at the print is
I have some holes but it's kind of like
a bowl tool routine on an inclined plane
so it gets a little different so right
now if I was to use a standard bolt hole
in this surface it would be working
around the surface but we do have an
option to kind of rotate it around so I
can create a plane and rotate it around
so from there oops
sorry I want to go back to my powerpoint
that one from here looks like the the
feed is slowing down a little bit
interesting let's get a chance to catch
up
Oh WebEx is a little slow today I'm
sorry but I
and and now we go to Mouse back okay
it was interesting slight technical
difficulty alright so we're going to
swivel cycle we're going to do a
drilling operation we're going to use a
face B but we're not going to drill just
on the plane we create we're actually
going to use a C axis rotation option so
here I can use a face be drilling
strategy with a face be selection in my
bolt hole routine but I can say with C
and that allows me to then basically
transfer that all the way around this
bolt hole powder this is going to be the
last feature we add so back in Sydney
train we're now going to create a final
plane and what's going to happen is this
plane is actually going to be back here
on this surface so I got to do a little
bit of a little bit more motion here
because this is where I'm going to
actually create my new zero it's going
to be back on this surface so we go to
swivel plane
I'm going to still use an 8 mil tool so
I can leave that in that's fine I
retract but now I'm not bringing my ex
up to 10 this corner I bring it all the
way up to this surface which is 25 mil
out right so I'm going to give it a
positive 25 my shift back is going to be
back to this corner so I'm sliding my
zero back z is still pointed straight
out from the surface 40 mil that could
be a negative 40 mil in Z all right so
shoot comes back then I'm going to do a
rotation of 45 degrees positive puts my
XYZ coordinates right here so X is
moving back to the surface Z is now
perpendicular ly out off the surface
wise across the part and I want to do a
final shift to get to the center of my
bolt hole for my print of positive 7 mil
in X that's going to plug that XYZ
coordinate system right there on that
bolt hole location and then from there
we can start our feature so zero is in
location I'm going to drill I'm just
going to do a basic drill ream I'm going
to still be using a face because I have
an inclined plane I want to take a look
at my depth steps a little deeper now
it's 45 mil per the print
what is going on here
you
boy that is awfully slow sorry about
that guys I'm not sure what's going on
my my feed is an issue okay so I have my
my drilling enabled now I want to go to
my position screen I'm going to do a
bolt hole pattern I gotta still use a
phase B strategy but now I want to use a
with C axis as well as as opposed to on
plane if I use on plane that's going to
give me a flat bolt hole pattern keeping
the C stationary if I use with C now
it's going to position around then I
just plug in where am I starting where
it's my Z datum it's zero in this case
whereas my XY 0 is going to be the
center of my bolt hole angle of my first
location and then how many do I want to
do and if we're right we should now have
a finish part
you
okay so it turns will let it simulate
the whole thing just give you a
refresher of holy opps slots we're going
to do our first peripheral face this is
actually a face wire sheath Y right for
a peripheral milling but we want to use
an x and y motion we index around face
off the next segment I'm going to
increase our speed a little bit little
hundred percent drill our holes drill
through back turn there's our first
surface second surface drill drill and
there is your bolt hole pattern wrapped
around
so as a recap really the biggest thing
from a technology side to kind of get
your head around is where's the
orientation of be in the spindle then
from there how do I Drive it so we're
going to start to use our beta and our
gamma fields to rotating things around
always mess with that method eyes
everything is if it's on the main
spindle the mirrored work horn I'll
handle all that I'm going to want to get
to my inclined planes I need to use the
swivel cycle and once I use the swivel
cycle any of them cycles I want to use I
have to then do a face beat option to
allow that that cycle to work on this
new inclined plane well the night you're
going to find this is going to drive
very very similar to a standard a
standard lathe so with that being said
that concludes our topic for today I
want to thank everybody for taking the
time out to to view or watch this
seminar and I hope to see you again real
soon